[Music]
foreign keep the change I'm gay
[Music]
[Applause]
the wait is over that 90s show is
finally here and guess what it's
fantastic as a huge fan of That 70s Show
I was a little worried it wouldn't match
the charm of the original series but it
like totally does cause this isn't gonna
work I'm pretty sure Oshkosh because
here is going to get carded While most
of the original casts do make
appearances Topher Grace Laura Prepon
Mila Kunis Ashton Kutcher and
wildervaldarama are all back but there's
a brand new cast of characters you'll
fall in love with and one of those
characters is Ozzy I want to come out to
your grandmother
wow okay
I you seem so confident and self-assured
I thought everyone knew I'm a gay kid
living in small town Wisconsin now
Aussie isn't struggling with his
sexuality he's gay and proud We love to
see it but there's one episode in
particular that I could relate to and I
think most queer people could as well
coming out and in an emotional moment
Ozzy comes out to Kitty
I'm gay
I've known for a while now and I wanted
you to know I even have a boyfriend
Etienne who lives in Canada now of
course the 90s were a very different
time for queer people so Aussie's not
sure how kitty will react and well take
a look
oh sweet boy get in here
you just made me feel really special
I'm not crying you're crying I love
Kitty's reaction so much and Ozzy is
just the best great job that 90s show
[Laughter]
[Music]